[THEME MUSIC]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KEPELMAN: Hello, I/O live.
Todd Kepelman here.
And I am joined
with Abe Haskins,
who is a Developer Programs
Engineer on the Firebase team.
Hi, Abe.
ABE HASKINS: Hi, Todd.
TODD KEPELMAN: So, what is
this exciting game that we see
going on behind us right here?
ABE HASKINS: This
is AppShip 2018.
This is a Firebase-powered,
multiplayer, arcade, spaceship,
thrilling game.
TODD KEPELMAN: Extravaganza.
ABE HASKINS: Extravaganza, yeah.
It's a phenomenon.
TODD KEPELMAN: That's
what I was thinking.
So how is this game
making use of Firebase?
ABE HASKINS: So we
started weeks ago
when we generated thousands
of custom rocket ships,
that we turned into sprites,
which we turned into cards,
which we got printed.
We did that all with Cloud
Functions and other Google
technologies.
And then once we
had those printed,
we built scanners that can
scan the codes using the new ML
kit from Firebase.
Then we made a game,
which received updates
from the scanner using
real-time database.
Once you're in the game, it
loaded your actual sprites
from cloud storage for Firebase.
And once you're in
the game doing stuff,
it shoots out analytics to
Google Analytics for Firebase.
So it's all Firebase,
through and through.
TODD KEPELMAN: Yeah, I
noticed every attendee here
is getting a AppShip.io
card, each one
with a unique rocket on it.
Did you design all
these rockets by hand?
ABE HASKINS: I basically did.
We made a tool that
allowed you to go
and mass produce rockets
by picking and choosing
parts that went together.
TODD KEPELMAN: This is mine,
with my custom spaceship.
And basically, when
you scan it in,
at these scanners over there,
everybody just sort of has
their own spaceship
magically appear in the game.
And so that's all being
powered through Firebase?
ABE HASKINS: It's all being
powered through Firebase.
Like I said, we used Cloud
Functions to actually generate
the sprites, generate the cards,
and we have the cards printed,
and we connected all
the cloud storage.
Real time database,
so we're writing back
when you scan it it.
We have history
on all the cards.
TODD KEPELMAN: So,
there's a lot that's
been going on with Firebase.
What for you, what are your
highlights of the things that
have been happening with
Firebase over the last year?
ABE HASKINS: Well, I
personally normally
work on Cloud FireStart,
so I was super excited
that we got to launch that.
But we also have
performance monitoring,
for keeping your
eye on your app,
we have A/B testing for
trying out new things.
We have ML kit, which
is obviously a huge--
everything about ML is
exciting and awesome.
I'm glad I got to use
it a little bit here.
Basically, all that.
We have so much cool
stuff coming out.
TODD KEPELMAN: Excellent.
Well, I'll have to
check out more of it
after I play a little
AppShip.io and, I don't know,
kick your butt in it.
All right, let's give it a try.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KEPELMAN: So every
attendee at I/O this year
has a unique AppShip.io
card that they can get here
at the Firebase Booth Dome.
And every card has a
unique rocket design on it.
So when you scan this QR code
at one of these scanners,
my special rocket will
appear on screen there.
That's me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[THEME MUSIC]